up next a little advice for mark banks
from Iowa mark the spark baby blaze it
up Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
gobble-gobble a sonship advice I've been
married for 25 years
oh you're [ __ ] I'm great help me get
through anxiety I'm still dealing with
some [ __ ] so I been smoking some weed
and I got caught before doing that and
she wasn't happy about it but clearly in
a shed I thought it helps I started
again and I haven't told her yeah she
told me last time that I should tell her
before I try to do anything like this
and you agree to that so question is
should I tell her it seems to help with
anxiety or should I just keep on keepin
on
Oh PS Brendan Schaub you're the coolest
[ __ ] on this planet right now W
man whoa
obviously you your dad dude you gotta
keep me better contact with your parents
man because I a bad dude you [ __ ] tits
McGee let's mark the spark bro and that
he loved that dude that dudes blazing
high blazing blazing probably so high
he's hitting on you from a shed behind
his house while his wife is a Holly [ __ ]
hot [ __ ] right there dude I love your
shot I play the very end again where he
talked three I want to see what he says
I'm not going bad on him Oh PS Brendan
Schaub you're the coolest [ __ ]
on this planet right now
love you man pretty cool man what did I
die it is a nice guy man smoking the
weed here's the thing if it helped you
especially in 2019 right direct barely
got that man who gets mad at someone
smoking weed especially anxiety if your
girl's not down with it man then she's
not she's not the one I don't know if
you're getting high know what this is
his wife and now he's finding out 25
years later bro you'd still make
mistakes I would definitely tell her I
would 100% tell her and she's not cool
with it
she ain't the one like 25 years bro oh
my god this guy thought you were cool to
divorce what are you saying them what do
you think they're just gonna live down
the street from each other while he
smokes weed yes some of it if it makes
you better who's gonna hate on so it
makes you a better person
well that's a good point I think but I
think he's told the white that he would
let her know if he was gonna smoke it
and he didn't so for some reason he
likes keeping it a secret I think it's
like it's like the one thing he can do
that's like oh that his wife doesn't
know about so he must find some joy in
that yeah
sneaky yeah he likes to have something
of his own which i think is okay
I mean by not hurting anybody right
you're not hurting a cheating on her you
just said the jacking off the pornos in
this shed and getting high right
I keep getting high man yeah we do and
if she says you know she catches you
then fess up to it and say look there
you know and then just tell her the
truth whatever the reason is why you
wanted to keep getting high I wanted to
keep getting high because I liked doing
something that you don't know about you
know I like getting high makes my
anxiety better
dude I'll tell you about this if you're
gettin high and you got a wife a little
bit of weed to make your wife feel like
a brand-new woman you know take the sex
to a different place yeah she's
complaining about weed to get her high
and then eat her ass like groceries you
know I'm saying
25 years mix it up bro give it up give
it up give what up dude life advice
don't don't touch me watch me
oh my god let's go to cat and get a
woman's perspective I can't even live
right here 25 years bro keep smoking
that hitter you just give the guy 9
different pieces of advice man I'm
hoping some sticks
next one he's like you know I'm gonna
get her high and eat her ass I'm hoping
that one sticks now yeah you blow a
little weed smoke in the bedroom or
something booty all right but you could
take her on that tour but you know just
you need to be a liaison there with her
you need to like you know hit her high
and leave her in the other room for a
half hour you know and sneak around the
house and ring a bell dude no don't
don't scare don't don't don't get her
high and play [ __ ] the conjuring you
know the same I'll tell you this after
cats a suggestion cat what do you think
well why doesn't she like like I'm
smoking weed if it helps with anxiety
cuz she never smoked before I mean maybe
she should get it on the smoking that's
a cat and see or it could just be
something that he does away from her if
it helps him or Chur naughty little
secret yeah I mean who's he hurting it's
fine dude we had this kid named Caleb
right and so we got so high one time one
of us usable he was about to leave so
somebody snuck out and took his steering
wheel off his car right so then dude he
goes out to his car bro and he was up
there like seven minutes
he comes back inside and he's like uh
you can tell he's kind of nervous to
tell us you know he's like man I can't
find my steering wheel right and
everybody's like oh you are [ __ ] high
bro you're an idiot you know you're a
psychopath you know cause people just
throw that in you know and haha
and dude so we laughed for like ten
minutes all even he was laughing at the
fact I can't find my steering wheel
right so in the meantime that guy went
back out and put his steering wheel back
into his car right so then we all go out
there as a group and the skin was back
on bro any [ __ ] loss oh hi bro lost
his mind who checked himself in a mental
health center and it's still there still
in the health center in 28 years 29
years so is that nature or nurture you
know it seemed to work out for him well
it's I don't know it's it's kind of a
bigger discussion but but what I'm
saying do it is look get high bro you in
the shed you getting high I think you
secretly want to get busted by your lady
I think it adds a little bit of spark a
little bit of spice to your life
dude I say get high get your lady in
there get blunted together and send us
another video and yeah and tell us
what's going on I want to send that
Blair Witch sex tape in the shed Oh or
just sent a nice video introducing us to
your lady that worked
yeah like shoutout to this dude yeah
mark the spark maybe blaze up dude I
want to see you get heated and playoff
fluffy bunny to where you fill your
mouth with marshmallows bra puffs give
to yourself
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching